ference alors alice sapritch dormir à
peu ce soir puisque oui même fait ce
soir objectons et dans une boîte vous
ressemble par les boîtes noires mais
c'est exceptionnel parce qu'on fait là
une fête comme une grande fête parce que
vous partez de paris c'est pas tellement
merdique philippe matin sur je viens
justement pour faire un distinguo de au
théâtre y sont à feu v10 imagine que je
mentais après demain c'est pas vrai du
tout je pars le 4 janvier je suis encore
en vacances ou quatre rails et le 7
jeunes environ tournée en france avec
les tours débarré et c'est au moins
d'avril que je m'en bats pour l'afrique
ou à laval alors ça il fallait le dire
prix gershwin partisans match sur le
volant du rayonnement culturel de la
france c'est quand même plus important
que les derniers voyages de la comédie
française
peut-être oui pourquoi vous avez ses
terres un pêcheur de 10 ans absolument
pas le nombre quoi je pense d'abord que
vous défendez une pièce importante car
on sait la place qu'un clochard dans mon
jardin tient dans la version française
c'est amusant d'autre part vous êtes
vous même un personnage culturel même
sans texte tout ce que vous avez déjà
n'ont simplement pas vous imitez mi
temps et c'est alors est ce que vous
savez de quel oeil le public de couleur
on voit déjà
est-ce qu'il vous connaissent que vous
êtes connu au congo en tout cas je ne
sais pas si le public de couleur
mâconnais mais en france la public de
couleur même beaucoup alors je ne sais
pas ce que ça va donner là bas mais je
ne connais pas l'afrique je vous dirai
ça à mon retour
oui je sais pas c'est pas important vous
connaissiez pas la frite ou savoir si
l'afrique connaît sapritch et comment la
faillite va vous recevoir
philippe je fais aussi un distinguo vous
évidemment vous avez
une façon de rire avec moi et savait
très bien que ma carrière est une
carrière tout belge et le côté
dramatique la télévision je ne suis pas
si vous avez vous pouvez dormir le soir
dorton dr mai mais enfin je viens de
tourner un film avec mitran il a eu des
revenus ce qui n'est pas du tout j'ai
passé déjà non non non alors je peux
râle avoir vu le message il ya quand
même quand il avait dix émissions à la
télévision qu'il n'avait pas vu cela
m'est arrivé on se trompe de shon
d'accord il est plus lent mais enfin ma
carrière est une carrière mixte
oui pour le moment c'est du comics mais
l'année prochaine ça sera autre chose
qu'on va pas parler de matière la
version de série que ce we à thierry va
limiter et vodafone ont commencé par le
pam et maintenant c'est la dernière
nouvelle est d'ailleurs ce soir là qui
pleure pas je l'aimais bien sûr
non mais attention je crois que le vice
de sapritch c'est d'être imité mais par
vous seulement un excellent endroit que
dans ses aliments sains et rappelé du
midi thierry wipff également à la même
hauteur
oui mais oui nous sommes malheureusement
vrai nom mais c'est une question de
talent et de la nonchalance de
s'arranger du talent et où il est temps
qu'ils peuvent imiter
oui mais je ne veux pas que les sous
fifres de thierry mimi et j'ai remarqué
d'ailleurs que celui qui vous imitait et
qu'il n'était pas le luron vous imiter
le luron en train de vous isoler et bien
ça m'agace profondément 0
elle était alors jamais thierry le luron
a mérité davantage le surnom que vous
lui avez donné son nom qu'est ce qu'un
seul vous appelle le mégalo ça n'est pas
non plus une méga louvier ont aussi
aussi assez d'un autre style
oui et toi tu nous